well it's here now from Phil Robertson
who's the deputy Asian director at Human
Rights Watch and he says that Malaysian
authorities are risking the health of
the people that they've arrested the
authorities are claiming that these
people are undocumented that they don't
have the right to be in Malaysia the
problem is of course that by hurting
them into unsanitary immigration
detention centers it's a great way to
ensure they all end up with kovat 19
from a public health perspective this
was probably the most stupid thing that
the government of Malaysia could do what
they've done is send a signal to migrant
workers and others you know which number
in the millions in Malaysia that if you
see from someone's coming from the
Ministry of Health run the other way and
what we're going to see is a lack of
cooperation from the migrant communities
for any efforts by the government to try
to control kovat 19 because they
correctly fear they will be arrested and
hauled off into camps where they may
spend months in even years before
they're allowed to go home there's very
little recourse for those who have been
taken right now I think that they're
going to basically stay in these
immigration detention centers where we
have seen outbreaks of infectious
disease in the past and deaths of
migrants from things that were certainly
preventable